I also met Jade's uh Brazilian parents
oh yeah what's great that's great baby
what's great when you can meet like I've
met Adam Ray's parents yeah yeah I've
met Fahim not his dad because he doesn't
like the fact that femur stand-up but
like I've met him rather and his cousins
I just really like meeting comics
families because you get to see why they
are the way they are and Jade's parents
are so cool so educated and they're
Brazilian and they're just really nice
people and your dad's very funny and if
you just tell byte when he smiles his
eyes crinkle do they have accents my mom
does she's resilient I wish I could get
my mom's accent down I can't do it why I
don't know yet right Jade why do I do do
the faces they're so ugly when dead-on I
was like yeah she sounds like a doughnut
Ella like a impression of Donatella you
know is it difficult being with a
comedian like living with them because
you've been with Nick for like nine
years correct some no six or seven Wow
sometimes it's hard I want to say it's
not but sometimes I do feel like there's
some projects I really want to work on
that he gets to work on and I feel
jealous sometimes
I'm being honest well he was a writer
S&L yeah he's a very sitelink very good
stand-up I've had him open for me too we
help each other but sometimes it is hard
because you know you have your own
insecurities and they got kind of like
flared up yeah time so what what was
your experience cuz I know that you're
one of your ex-girlfriends is was also a
comedian yeah was it did you feel that
way well you guys yeah that's the
problem is is I feel like Jade and Nick
are on the same level the same yeah yo J
it's gotten some stuff nick has gotten
some stuff and I feel like they're more
of a power couple you know with with the
girl that I'd still do in comedy and I
hung out with her last night with I mean
Sunday night with Sarah
Sarah's her name with Margaret Cho very
very talented very funny and but we also
are an AAA together yeah so you have
I mean we're not and yeah I think that
and she's also I don't know she's a
great girl though and I think we ended
in a kind way it wasn't ugly we just
kind of you know naturally like and then
some relationships I've had you've had
I've had to be in a cold and the
Christine you know Christine yeah I do
yeah and I had to end it pretty cold
that Vegas trip was crazy crazy I think
was just a lot of well the first time we
went it was for Pauly Shores like
Showtime show what was it but I wasn't
there for the show for comedy I was
there doing promo work and I was so
broke that I crashed in the hotel room
with them at the same weekend yeah and I
was waking up like 6:00 a.m. working
till 6 p.m. in like high heels with like
it was April Macie Benjy know who was
performing though oh my god so funny oh
my god I have the best story from that
trip so are you walking down the street
yes so the palms in Rio the two hotels
are like pretty close together walking
distance bar part like a 15-minute walk
in Vegas which is used to live there yes
miles it's pretty cold we're out one
night we get wasted everyone's partying
me and Dave one of the guys who I went
to college with have this like wild
night where we're like kind of kissing
kind of Nod just like having fun
pretending we're getting married and
looking at rings like up all night we
sleep in the same bed fully clothed like
/ still I he wakes up he's like oh [ __ ]
I have a rock I have to take this ride
to the airport with Charlene and Bobby I
have to go and he like runs out and I
run out and I'm wearing like a tiny
dress from the night before like a tiny
purse and they're in the car and they
drive off and I'm walking from the Rio
to the palms or whatever the other and
they drive by me as I'm taking this like
walk of shame it's freezing outside and
there and Bobby just sticks his finger
out the window and just like haha
yeah and then I get two little telling I
realized that I had been jeez [ __ ]
Mercedes parked at I could have just
[ __ ] taking the car yeah yeah I was
yeah I left is that the trip where your
brother went to yes Steve Tuesday Steve
is a house Jay I love his heart's in his
eyes can we bonded that well we say it
have lunch all the time yeah you see in
the same room as Steve did you Stevie no
I stayed with Nicole booty oh yeah he's
under the impression that I think you
guys had a love connection we did you
think you bonded but he thinks it was
like real long did we fell in love
yeah we fell in line kid he does that a
lot
yeah so cute he'd he drew me my favorite
portrait ever I have it framed it man oh
you do yeah we drew a picture of you
yeah and I have like a beard in it
that was probably shading yeah that's
what I love about it so bad
[Music]